the thoughts and emotions that you
create you don't have to find any
solution for it you should just turn it
off it's gone it's time that human
potential is unleashed because we are
the first generation on the planet for
whom our survival is organized better
than ever before if you think you know
everything or you believe you know
everything you will be just too full of
yourself the top need motivation watch
top ten with belief nation
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and chew in today's lessons
from a man who went from moving around a
lot as a kid loving adventure and travel
and motorcycles growing up to having a
life-changing spiritual experience and
then devoting his life to spirituality
and founding the Isha Foundation he's a
guru and here's my take on his top ten
rules a success volume for joy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one
turn off the problems it's time to
understand all the problems of
individual nature are generated from
with him and we don't have to solve
problems that we create we just have to
dissolve no problems that you create you
don't have to solve if there is a
problem in the situation yes we have to
solve but you have a problem within you
solution is not what you need solution
is madness solution means for an
illusion you're creating an illusionary
solution something that you make up for
that you create one more solution that
you made up once again now you just have
to turn off the problems you're going
through a certain drama only thing is
you're a lousy director that's all there
is instead of improving your direction
now you're trying to find a solution for
a situation in a drama it's like people
watch the cinema and come home and they
have big arguments about what happened
there so the thoughts and emotions that
you create you don't have to find any
solution for it you should just turn it
off it's gone if you find solution you
moving towards insanity because you
create a ghost and you create a
Ghostbuster the ghost that you create
you must learn to play with them hello
I'm saying if nobody willing to play
with you you have to play with somebody
right
so the ghosts you create if you like
them you play with them if you don't
like them turn them off but Sadhguru
they keep coming
[Applause]
you don't play don't like to play with
them don't play they come and go
never it ever happen that one thought
remained for more than a moment isn't it
it comes and goes comes and goes
let it come and go if you try to find a
solution for that you will head towards
insanity
rule number two my personal favorite
unleash your potential you told the
story of a mane who had wings but never
used them to fly and just reproduce and
had a life and isn't it a tragedy that
he never used his wings to fly do you
feel like most of us are walking through
life with wings and we never use them to
fly unfortunately yes
a whole lot of people too many people
mm-hmm it's time that human potential is
unleashed because we are the first
generation on the planet for whom our
survival is organized better than ever
before ever be so this is the time to
unlock our potential to lose those all
kinds of inhibitions and fears that we
had there was a time if as much as cloud
gathered and lightning and thunder
happened without God was angry with us
okay okay all those things are gone it
is time you take away the nonsense
that's happening within you and the
entire process the science of inner
engineering is just this how to work at
it in a scientific manner not with
philosophy I can tell you a thousand
times give up your fear it's not going
to go but if your chemical soup is
blissful
there's not even a idea of fear in your
mind it reminds me of your concept of
the movies you play the movies in your
mind you can choose a drama you can
choose a horror story or you can choose
a positive movie and not get stuck in
the same movie
forever you can turn it off and start a
new one yeah but for that you should
know where the switches are right you
are like a supercomputer but you haven't
found the keyboard yet time to find the
keyboard that's my work to give people
the keyboard to their supercomputer rule
number three seek knowledge see the
reason the only reason a human being
will seek to know something is because
he realizes that he does not know if he
does not realize that he does not know
there will be no longing to know there
will be no seeking to know and
definitely there will be no knowing it's
not possible whether it is spiritual
seeking or any other kind of knowledge
you will seek only because you realize
you do not know if you think you know
everything or you believe you know
everything you will be just too full of
yourself that's all and that is a huge
problem that's a very big problem though
we have a culturally cultivated humility
that you see all over the place
everybody is like this only but still
too full of yourself when you bend
nothing goes out of your head it doesn't
make any space I am saying because my
head is open that's why I'm bandaged can
you see rule number four be truthful to
yourself one thing that you must do to
yourself is you are absolutely truthful
to yourself if you're also truthful to
everybody around you you will get other
kinds of benefits with people but I will
not go that far right now with yourself
you're 100% truthful otherwise all kinds
of tricks keep happening
to be truthful to yourself is not a easy
thing because there is lifetimes of
habit of simply both yourself our guest
came to Shankaran Pillai house and being
a South Indian man down south you know
the lights come from further down south
he was carrying an umbrella which is
common thing in Kerala and southern
Tamil Nadu to carry a nun realize a very
common thing because rains can be very
heavy then they walked out he took the
guest out then he started raining that
Shankaran Pillai did not open the
umbrella the guest said why don't you
open the umbrella
Shankaran Pillai said I'm sorry number
lights full of holes then the guests
asked why did you bring it well I never
thought it will rain today a whole lot
of people are like this they think
somebody else has to catch their lives
this will take a long time because
someone else catching your life will
take lifetimes you must catch them you
should not let your chickens pass to
become 100 percent straight with
yourself you take a certain amount of
application but if this one thing you do
I saw Thomas Adama this piece of life
will work for sure 100% then figuring
out a few things is very simple for that
I'm there if you just fix one this this
one thing that you're 100 percent
straight no any kind of deception then
there's a hole in the umbrella you know
there is a hole in the umbrella you will
never forget that there is a hole in
number Allah
okay if you are like this rest of the
work becomes very simple and easy rule
number five make the best of every
experience how to address the larger
issues of my life there are no large
issues in your life what is the large
issue that you are talking about it is
just about what job to take which girl
to marry
where to go for vacation whether whether
to get married or not get married you
know little things isn't it these are
not large issues these are little things
in your life yes or is it just a small
thing whom I get married to I'm not
saying it's a small thing but as an
issue it's a small issue little issue as
a consequence to your life yes it has
many things but this is something that
human beings have done for millions of
years
we have enough experience on these
things isn't it we know that whatever
job we take whoever we marry it is just
a way we make out of it every experience
of life you can make it an enriching
experience every experience in your life
you can make a curse out of it see there
is nothing wrong in your job whatever
job you're doing there's nothing wrong
getting this job there's nothing along
wrong and losing this job there is
nothing wrong in getting married there's
nothing wrong in getting divorced
there's nothing wrong in not getting
married there is nothing wrong in
anything there is nothing wrong in this
or that but it is just that you make
misery out of it that's wrong if you do
this you make misery out of it if you do
that you make misery out of it that's
what is wrong with you
so you got married is it wrong that's
not the point there's nothing wrong with
it you did not get married is it wrong
no there's nothing wrong with it that's
wonderful - you got divorced is it wrong
no that's also wonderful it is just that
you make misery out of everything that's
what is wrong you just address that one
issue everything will be settled rule
number six live a full fledged life
people are always thinking that
something else if somebody else is
restricting their freedom but once
freedom is lost simply because they are
tangled up with their own body and their
own mind these are two dimensions of you
two faculties unless your body and your
mind is fully in your hands if they're
continuously working for you never
against you
only then you can live a successful life
people have approached in a well-being
either with belief systems or
philosophies or ideologies or some wacky
ideas of their own it's time to approach
your inner well-being in a scientific
manner as the science and technology to
create external well-being there is a
whole science and technology to create
inner well-being that is what we call as
calling as inner engineering
technologies for well-being it is time
that you approach your inner well-being
also in a scientific systematic way and
employed technologies to create this
well-being everything else you using
technology you understand that
technology can facilitate everything on
the outside why don't you understand
that does the best piece of technology
on this planet is this human mechanism
unless you approach it properly it will
not Eve living here is half a human
being is not good enough right now
people's idea of success is they're
doing better than their neighbor now
your idea of success should be that you
are a full fledge life because this is
not my idea this is not my philosophy
this is the longing of every life every
worm insect bird tree animal and also a
human being are always striving to
become a full-fledged life but we know
what is a full fledge worm we know what
is a full fledged insect we know what is
a full fledged apple tree but we don't
know what's a full fledge human being
that's where the problem is rule number
seven don't conquer embrace the purpose
of business or the purpose or the goals
of big business is to expand you can
expand in two different ways one is by
conquest another is by embrace I can
conquer you or I can embrace you both
ways you will become mine if I embrace
you you will become mine willingly and I
will have better use of you in every
possible way I am talking business not
this not my personal thing but if I
concur you I will still have you but I
have to sit on top of your head and make
you do things and you will do everything
possible to make my life miserable
yes or not roof absolutely so people are
trying to conquer and their businesses
and their activity is doing everything
possible to make them miserable and you
can see it on their faces successful
people are showing miserable faces which
is a wrong message to send to the world
particularly to the youth if you send a
message that success is misery you're
destroying humanity success is the
sweetest thing that can happen to human
being but now you take the most
successful 10,000 people on the planet
you will see there are an epitome of
tension and anxiety and misery you are
sending a completely wrong message this
you can see took such a bad turn in
United States of America in the 60s the
so called corporates brutally wanting to
grow conquer the world set such an image
of themselves
the youth thought it's better to sit in
the street corner and smoke pot and it's
a better way to live at least you're
happy you're not causing any damage to
anybody this is a horrible way to exist
so it's extremely important that
successful people send a clear message
success is a beautiful thing it is not a
suffering it is not a miserable thing to
do in your life if this has to happen
your expansion has to happen by embrace
not by conquest rule number eight find
stability spiritual process means to
become like a mountain stable still
because it's only when somebody has a
very stable base many things can be done
the exuberance of life is possible
only if there is absolute stability
otherwise exuberance will lead to
madness
that's why a lot of people what a little
creative little active little exuberant
always end up being freaky and literally
insane because without stability you
cannot have a dance going this is why
save I mean stillness shiva means dance
at the same time either you see him
sitting absolutely still or you see man
an explosion of dance because an
explosion is possible only when there is
a stable base an explosion which is not
destructive is possible only when there
is stability and stability people try to
become stable by controlling and
trimming their lives this is the way
your grandmother would tell you how to
be stable control yourself then you will
be stable yes if you're dead you will be
stable very I promise you that so
normally people who talk about stability
are all constipated existence you know
what's constipation that means it
happens little by little
[Music]
their joy their love their ecstasy
happens little by little here and there
that's constipation so stability is not
because you have trimmed your life down
or pruned it down to minimal and you're
stable that's of no consequence
stability because you see everything are
totally clearly that is why when we say
hatha yogi we're talking about stability
at the same time an exuberant dance this
is possible only because here's more
than two eyes not necessarily three more
than two that means this is much more
than most people ever see because he
sees much much more able to be stable
stability it takes to allow exuberance
to happen otherwise you keep curtailing
your exuberance because it hurts when
it's out of balance if you are out of
balance and you move at a certain speed
you're going to hurt yourself whether
you are riding a bicycle or you riding
the cosmos if you are out of balance and
you attain speed you're going to hurt
yourself very badly so balance is very
important and balance that comes out of
curtailment is not balanced that's you
know package debt rule number nine
reduce friction so you must understand
this if everything that you try to do is
becoming friction friction is happening
obviously you're the sandpaper know it's
a sin people
I'll ask them to provide you a sample a
small piece every day whenever you have
a friction with somebody just scrape
your skin somewhere so if you don't cure
yourself quickly you won't have any skin
left when you don't have any skin left
then you will not touch anything
you will not create it you will not look
for any friction you will walk in
suppose you had no skin
how would you walk even a little feather
won't touch you like that you will walk
isn't it because everything hurts now so
if you want that kind of treatment we
can do otherwise first come to your
senses friction is happening means
wherever you go friction is happening
obviously to one simple thing you can do
to reduce friction is I've told you many
times but you've not done this ease
whatever you're saying in a day or in an
hour or in a minute how many words per
minute are you uttering bring it down to
50% still do the same work you will see
a whole lot of friction will go down
simply because you're not blabbering yes
and we've been trying to train you
whatever you see whether you see a man
woman child cow donkey donkey also
No
how will friction not happen it will
happen so when you insert the gurus here
like this first of the time like this it
won't work bring this into you not just
as a symbolism genuinely so friction of
two kinds one within ourselves outside
is just an expression and the
consequence so this whole thing about in
the engineering means just this that
when you sit here you can sit here
without any friction if you can sit here
without any friction outside friction
also will go down but when you meet a
sandpaper there must be some friction
there are sand papers hello so when you
meet the sandpaper there must be
friction otherwise how there will be so
generally we avoid with sandpaper if we
can but sometimes we have to work with
them when we have to work with the
sandpaper you need tact this is
something you have to learn this will
not come this is not anything spiritual
about it this is tacked in the society
sometimes it doesn't work but it's a
question of skill some people who are
not spiritual in any way they are very
tactful when they meet sandpapers you
will see this kind of agents and others
or working in government offices and in
political atmospheres they are so smooth
it doesn't matter how rough the other
person is these people just they'll just
get the job done and leave
so working with sandpaper takes a little
bit of skill and experience nothing
spiritual about it it's a social skill
but generally in there are some very few
sent papers once in a way people pop-ups
and on them but they drop it you know
they don't keep it all the time
sometimes sometimes they're like that
they're not like that all the time so
when they are like that when the
porcupine has its thing up you must just
keep away a bit when it's done you can
talk to it it doesn't keep it up all the
time it doesn't have the strength to do
that so your friction
you must understand it's just you and
will number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is tell great
stories on a certain day a bull and a
pheasant were grazing bull was chomping
the grass pheasant was picking off
picking ticks off the bull partnership
the huge tree at the edge of the field
the pheasant very nostalgically looked
at the tree and sad Oh alas there was a
time I could fly to the topmost branch
of the tree now I do not have enough
strength in my wing even to get to the
first branch the bull very nonchalantly
said that's no issue just heat a little
bit of my tongue every day within a
fortnight you'll get their present said
come on what kind of rubbish is that the
bull said really try and see the whole
humanity is on it
so very hesitantly the pheasant started
pecking at that down and low on the very
first date reached the first branch of
the tree within a fortnight it reached
the topmost branch of the tree just
beginning to enjoy the scenery an old
farmer I was rocking on his rocking
chair saw a fat old pheasant sitting on
top of the tree pulled out his shotgun
and shot the bird off the tree the moral
of the story is many times even [ __ ]
can get you to the top but it never lets
you stay there
[Music]
I've got a really special bonus sadguru
clip on how to shift your perspective
but before that question today I want to
know which clip resonated more with you
shift your perspective or turn off the
problems let me know leave it down the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clip
anything that you don't understand you
will call it a miracle isn't it suppose
you don't know what is electricity and I
tell you you just watch this and want to
press that wall and this hall will be
flooded with light would you believe me
you won't believe me you'll say no such
things are not possible now if I press
it and suddenly there's light everywhere
now you think either I'm son of God
Messenger of God of God Himself
depending upon which culture you come
from is it anything that you don't
understand is a miracle in your
understanding either there is no miracle
in life everything happens between cause
and effect or everything is a miracle
isn't this life a miracle you are me
sitting here on this round planet which
is going at a tremendous speed is it not
a miracle we sitting here and talking
all this nonsense is it not a miracle so
if you look at it if you have eyes to
see everything is a miracle oh nothing
is a miracle these are two ways to
approach life these are two forms of
yoga one is to see everything as sacred
another is to see everything as after
nonsense but now your problem is what
you like is sacred what you don't like
is nonsense that's a problem that's a
trap everything is sacred this is a
beautiful way to live everything is
nonsense that is also very beautiful way
to live what these people are sacred
these people are nonsense this will
destroy you right now you chose on that
isn't it this is sacred this is not
sacred this would work if you tell
yourself a story long enough you start
to believe it
you believe you act like I have Tulsa
what a wail out of handcuffed lightning
throw Thunder in jail now you know I'm
bad over the last week I murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between 18 and 250 4 days of taking
action for a new habit to stick I've
created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for 254
days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access